[Music]
hey what's up guys and welcome to my
tutorial for the ninja star fidget
spinner I really like this spinner
because you can spin it on the paperclip
or you can even spin it on the table and
it's a lot of fun for this tutorial I'm
going to be using a red and a blue
printer sheet which are my two favorite
colors but in total we're only going to
be using half of a printer sheet so that
means you can make 4 ninja stars with 2
sheets I'll also be using a Bic pen for
the cartridge that's inside however most
other pens will have a suitable
cartridge we're also going to cut the
tip off of the pen cartridge so if you
have a pair of scissors pliers or even a
knife that'll be very helpful and I'm
going to be using a paper clip either
large or small whichever one you guys
have is fine if you don't have the pen
cartridge it's ok it'll still spin on
the paper clip but just not as well so
grab all your supplies and let's get
started but I do have a surprise for you
guys I'm also going to teach you the
origami infinity kaleidoscope in a
separate video so be sure to check that
out by clicking on the link and the
upper right hand side of the video this
is really cool as it spins like this
forever and it looks really awesome
alright so I'm just going to set these
pens which I'm going to be using aside
they're the round stick extra life ones
and these are the paper clips I'm going
to be splitting both of these papers in
half first so that you have a sheet like
this and then I'm going to be splitting
these halves in half so I'm basically
going to be having two quarters of a
piece of paper in order to make the
ninja star and this is the easiest way I
know how to make it so I'm just
basically going to split them in half
and speed it up a little bit just gonna
take the top edge fold down to the
bottom edge and run my fingernail
against that crease really hard so I
could tear it up and down just like that
then do the same thing fold the top edge
down to the bottom and then I could tear
it again you can also use scissors if
you want once I have the two quarters of
the paper I'm gonna make sure that
they're horizontal then I'm going to
take the top edge and fold it down to
the bottom edge on both of the sheets
once the edges are lined up then you can
make a crease along the top of the paper
like that and if you want you could run
your fingernail against the top of the
edge to make sure there's nice and sharp
and do the same with the other paper
fold it down line up the edges and then
make
once I've done that for both of the
sheets I'm going to take the left side
of the paper and fold it to the right
edge just like this take it across line
up the edges here and then I'm going to
make a crease here on the left and if
you want again run your fingernail
against it to make sure that crease is
nice and sharp do the same with the
other sheet fold it across line up the
edges and then make that crease on the
left now when you open up the paper
you'll see that you have a vertical
crease in the paper just like that I'm
going to make a mark on the vertical
line just so you could see it you don't
need to make one though now I'm going to
take the left side on the bottom and
it's going to go up and the right side
is going to go down on the vertical
crease so take the left edge fold it up
onto that crease just like that and
increase it along this edge here hold
the right side the top edge is going to
go on to that line just like that and
then again make a crease on the top
right here do the same with the other
side left goes up right goes down and
there you go now I'm just going to take
both of the sheets and I'm going to flip
them over like that now you'll see we
have an edge here in the paper on the
top and the bottom here I'm going to
take the top of the paper and fold it
down directly next to that edge once
they're touching like that I'm going to
make a crease on the top here same with
the bottom bottom goes up next to the
edge and then make a crease on the
bottom here do the same with the other
one top goes down and the bottom goes up
so you should have two papers that look
like this now I'm going to take the
upper right corner and fold it down to
the lower left corner so just take the
upper right corner and I'm going to fold
it across the diagonal just like this
you might have to round the paper off a
little bit so it folds better line it up
with the left side like that and then
just make a crease now the bottom left
corner is going to go to the upper right
corner by folding across this diagonal
take it fold it up
and then you can crease it along the
edge so now your paper should look just
like this and as you'll see it looks
like a Z if you hold it like that so I
have a Z here and I'm gonna do the same
with this piece upper right corner down
to the lower left corner bottom left
corner to the upper right corner so now
I have another Z so both of the pieces
should look exactly the same now I'm
going to take the top triangle and fold
it down and I'm going to take the bottom
triangle and fold it up if they don't
want to fold make sure that these two
edges are touching like this so if
they're overlapping just pull it like
that and then crease it okay same here
top triangle goes down and the bottom
triangle goes up then you can flatten
them out and you're ready to join the
pieces up so you should have two pieces
of paper that look exactly like this to
join up the pieces again just open up
these triangles and then we could take
the one on the right again make sure it
looks like a Z and flip it 90 degrees
like that then I'm going to put the one
on the right on top of the one on the
left so that it has an X in the middle
like that they're crossed okay so it
should look just like this now I'm going
to take the red one which is the bottom
one and I'm going to take the bottom
triangle and the bottom triangles gonna
go into the middle first so one and it's
gonna go in a clockwise direction the
second one is the blue one two three now
it doesn't if it doesn't want to fold
you just need to move it around a little
bit like that and then again just move
it back into place so you should have
something that looks like this and the
last one is going to go over this edge
and it's going to go into that little
pocket right here so if you want to
stick your fingernail in here and just
lift up that pocket there like that or
better yet if you want to take a little
bit of a pen and just open that up like
that now you can take the last one and
it's gonna go over here and into there
so just round it off a little bit like
that
just bend it like this put the tip into
the pocket
and then just push it in all the way
like that
once it's in then you could just flatten
it out and you've completed the easiest
ninja star now let's make it into a
spinner all I do now is basically take
the end of a paper clip and poke a hole
in the middle of the ninja star by
putting it right here and just be
careful because it can be sharp put your
fingers on opposite ends of that little
line and just kind of push it until it
goes through just like that now you can
just rotate it a little bit and open up
the hole and as you'll see it will spin
on the paperclip like that but not that
good so just take it out take the pen
and I'm just gonna put the tip right in
the middle and just wiggle it until it
goes through a little bit again watch
your fingers when you're doing that once
it goes through like that so you could
see the little tip like that then you
could take it out Oh
as you'll see got a little stuck in
there but the next thing I want to do is
to pop this out if it doesn't come out
that easy for you by putting your finger
there what you can do take the scissors
and just kind of get it in that groove
that's right there between the pen tip
and the rest of the pen there's a little
groove you'll see here put the scissors
in and you could just squeeze it a
little bit and that'll pop it out take
it out and you'll see this about an inch
here but we're just going to use a pinky
width or a bout a centimeter take the
scissors put it right there at the
centimeter and just aim it down like
this and squeeze because it's gonna fly
away so now we have that little clear
plastic tube and I'm just gonna take it
and I'm gonna put the end that we cut
right through the middle like that and
push it through so that you have about
the same amount on the back as you do on
the front like that and there you go
all you need to do put it on the
paperclip
now if you want to open up the paperclip
a little bit more like this unfold it
then you can actually move it back and
forth along the paperclip like that
[Music]
there you go there's your ninja star
spinner thank you guys so much for
watching my tutorial for the ninja star
spinner I hope you guys liked it thank
you to everyone who voted in my poll in
my last video that I had I do have a lot
of ideas for tutorials that I like to
teach this month of December so I hope
you guys enjoy them again do you want to
see the infinity kaleidoscope I am going
to try to teach this but leave me a
comment let me know if you guys
definitely want to see it and I am
working on it but if you want to see
something else let me know in the
comments below and also don't forget to
subscribe by clicking the little button
somewhere in the middle the video here I
do have other tutorials that you can
watch in other videos I'll have them
posted here on the screen also click
that notification bell so you could
become part of my notification squad
thank you guys so much for watching
again and I'll see you next time